- I heard this crazy story.
I don't know if it's true, but it's about,
yes, with you.
With Sir Rod.
So, the first time you
saw the Rolling Stones,
they were doing blues
music at like a little,
was it like a pub or theater?
What was it?
- Oh, it was a place
called Eel Pie Island.
It was a little ballroom in Twickenham
and there was 12 people there.
- 12 people.
And Mick's girlfriend was a
girl called Chrissy Shrimpton,
who's a sister of the great
model, Jean Shrimpton.
And my girlfriend, his
girlfriend were friends
and they said, "Come and see my singer,
"my boyfriend, he's a singer."
She said, "Oh, my
boyfriend's a singer, too."
So, I went over there and watched
and there was literally nobody there.
And they were all sitting
on stools playing, you know.
- But they were doing like blues music?
- Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Brian Jones was in the band then.
Ane then within six months to a year bash,
that was it, they took off.
- Yeah, those moments are just so cool.
Like once again, like you
busking and people not knowing
and then you sitting there
and not knowing.
- Yeah.
- What that band would become, yeah.
It's incredible.
- I think the blues
in Britain was a big thing,
so that's where I started as well.
The playing little pubs,
playing blues stuff,
'cause that's what we all heard.
It was a thing you got people dancing.
- [Kelly] 'Cause it makes such an impact.
Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like here, there's a lot of music
you just listen to for
fun, but not much that,
I mean, feels like
really moves you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, or that's what
I like to listen to.